la grisaille du jour était de
circonstance pour la visite de jack
meeting c'est ici au coeur de la réserve
grossesse saskatchewan qu'ont été
retrouvés les restes humains de sept
cent cinquante et une personnes en
majorité des enfants autochtones de
l'ancien pensionnat local
allons le débit au bar minable pointe et
ému le chef néo démocrate promet de
faire la lumière qui étaient ses enfants
que leur est-il arrivé
le npd nommerait un procureur spécial
pour enquêter c'est une génocide causés
par le gouvernement l'êta a tué les
enfants stockton californie
la vérité fait mal dit le chef cadmus
delorme mais elle est nécessaire pour
continuer notre réconciliation
justin trudeau ne promet pas d' enquêtes
spéciales mais rappelle son bilan on
investit des sommes records pour être
partenaire avec les peuples autochtones
pour améliorer les choses et
effectivement il faut en faire encore
bien plus
[Musique]
en matinée l'assemblée des premières
nations québec labrador a proposé qu'on
offre à ses citoyens un contrat et des
engagements comme celui que les
conservateurs viennent de présenter aux
québécois erin ou tour ne s'y engage pas
mais promet que les autochtones seront
une priorité je vais toujours travaillé
en partenariat avec les premières
nations au québec et de l'ancien à l'eau
la réconciliation est une priorité pour
moi historiquement les autochtones ne
vote pas beaucoup aux élections
fédérales en 2019 seulement 52% des
électeurs inscrits dans les réserves
étaient allés aux urnes les premières
nations veulent maintenant des actions
plus concrètes pour faire la paix avec
leur passé une réconciliation qui
peut-être les incitera à voter davantage
et si jean sébastien cloutier radio
canada sur la réserve de la nation
cowessess en saskatchewan